hello and welcome lab roots users
i'm coming to you today from tucson
arizona
the home of roche tissue diagnostics
montana and the university of arizona my
name is tom grogan
i'm a professor of pathology
from the university and the founder of
roche
tissue diagnostics my field of expertise
was the study of lymphoma
in mainly studying what explained
response to therapy and what explained
failure to respond to therapy and
my experience founding
roche ventana was that i wanted better
tools than i had
to understand what explained
responses to therapy
today's topic is the importance of
tissue chemistry in
immuno-oncology which is coming to you
on the 3rd of june
there are four parts to the presentation
uh first we'll talk
in general terms about concepts
surrounding immunotherapy
and then secondly i want to go give you
a deeper dive
into the clinical experience of
immunotherapy
by going into detail about a patient on
immunotherapy
and then in the third segment i want to
go beyond the one patient
to a couple of population-based
studies which really bring us to what i
would call the universalization of
immunotherapy
then finally to end on where is all of
this going
and what may we expect next
so let's start in general terms
talking about immunotherapy and first
really a
historical point which is in the last 50
years
the advent of effective immunotherapy
is probably the biggest change
the greatest progress in the treatment
of cancer
of any other development in fact
it's the importance of this
the understanding of it the elucidation
of the targets of immunotherapy
is recognized in 2018 with a nobel prize
which went to james allison
and takashi hanzo
they elaborated this phenomenon of the
blockage of immune response
to cancer and that's what we're going to
get into
and on the heels of that and they
had the implication from the work that
blocking the blockade might solve
the problem of immune inhibition and
pharma
acted on that and acted in spades to
produce this next generation of
anti-blockade drugs and
the revelation has been that i'm calling
them drugs i mean generally
they are humanized monoclonal antibodies
the revelation has been that this
may lead to restoration of
immunosurveillance
in a phenomenon that we could call
self-healing
so let's talk for a minute about
immunosurveillance
that's the aspect of your immunity
which is your protective cellular
response to foreign antigens
you and i are alive right now because we
have this capability
it's an it's an important part of our
being in good health it takes a very
particular form
in the matter of cancer cells
mutated cancer cells that produce um
foreign antigens that there's a specific
t
cell response it's
much of the effect or cell response is
by cda t
cells and that infiltrate the tumor
and they there's so there's a
characteristic
immunologic definition of these cells
and there's a characteristic spatial
definition
and so the really what you want
is to have a tumor with a very strong
tumor infiltrating
lymphocyte response by activated cd8
cells
and that is the desire
but where we start with
is a prelude to cancer often
is the loss of immunosurveillance and
there are a few of those
situations that are logical for example
you could have the hiv virus have aids
you've lost your t cell capability
you will lose your ability for
self-healing
and those patients in that situation
may die of malignancies
it happens when you get older that
there's immunosine essence and the nobel
prize
went for describing that there
can be a molecular basis for the loss of
immunosurveillance
called acquired immune resistance
and the immune blockade
is an understandable phenomenon that
eliminate
limits the physiologic response to
inflammation
it has a positive physiologic definition
and the revelation was that
tumor cells could take on that chemistry
and block the immune response
so immune blockade the surprise
was that cancer cells could
block host till responses to tumor
antigens
that was new to medical science and it
comes down to the fact
that there's a very specific chemistry
now there are a number of elements in
the response inhibition
i'm going to focus particularly on one
of those
combinations and that is when the tumor
up regulates
program death ligand 1 and binds to
program death
1 on t cells at the very end i'll
mention
some of the other factors that are
involved
but this complex of pdl1 and pd1
inhibits cda till activation
and amazingly invasion it not only makes
that t cell inactive
it also immobilizes it so if you think
of cd8 cells
as the wolves of the immune system this
has
not only stopped the
wolves from hunting it it hasn't
mobilized them
and the revelation again is that
anti-blockade therapy
typically in the form of a humanized
antibody to either
pdl-1 or pd and block the blockade and
restore self healing
so this is presented in diagrammatic
form right here
and in the lower left is a tumor and
the yellow antigens you would see
as mutated antigens uh passed
on the anagen to antigen
processing cells dendritic cells
trafficking to a lymph node and
stimulating a t
cell response and the product of that
response
are the cd8 positive cytotoxic cells
that then are informed
to attack the tumor and so on the right
side
we we see in every step of this exchange
there's a whole chemistry to it the one
i'm going to emphasize is on the lower
right
and that's when the the tumor puts up
a pdl-1 that
promotes pd-1 on
t cells and inactivates them
and this process has shown can be
blocked
with humanized monoclonal antibodies
so um what we're talking about is a
phenomenon called
acquired immune resistance it's not a
genetic change
it's a reaction to foreign antigen
it's a rate limiting reaction on the
immune system
and it's it's the creation of a
phenotypic
force field and we're going to come back
again to this word
phenotypic again
now so those are the general concepts we
have
uh let's let's go into the example
of a patient um who
um was treated with immunotherapy
and get into some of the details about
how this patient came to that
immunotherapy
first of all it's a 70 year old male
with a malignant melanoma
right on the top of his head it was
deeply invasive
with lymph node involvement and it had
something called
satelitosis so it was classified as a
stage
3b with an 80 probability of relapse
and the fact is uh with that relapse the
probability
that that patient will survive it is
very low
so it is a lethal
circumstance that's the bad news
the good news is on initial uh
evaluation we find that there is a b
raft mutation and there is an anti-b
raft drug
so maybe this can be dealt with
the example i'm relating to you
comes from a book called chasing the
invisible which i've just published and
the subtitle is a doctor's quest to
abolish the last unseen cancer cell
and it's my account over these 50 years
of patients in the very circumstance of
the patient i'm talking about
so it's a collection of such patients
and it's also an account of how tissue
chemistry
and and in particular
immunohistochemistry really
informed the treatment of these patients
so back to our patient our patient um
you can barely make out near the middle
of the screen
there are five or six little ink dots
and they're surrounding
this little fleshy nodule about the size
of a pea
and it turns out that is a truly nasty
malignant melanoma with an 80
probability of killing this patient
it seems entirely improbable that a
little bump on your skin
could kill you but that's the danger of
this disease
and when you look at the here at the
histology in the left
you're seeing purple and pink and that's
because
we're staining this a section of this
pea-sized tumor
with hematoxylin and eosin the
hematoxylin is purple
staining the nucleic acid and the pink
is uh showing us the protein
and at the very top of the screen is the
surface
of that epidermis and radiating down
into the connective tissue are islands
of primitive tumor cells
with a high nucleic acid to protein
content
and we think of that as a primitive
undifferentiated tumor
in fact maybe it's a metastasis from
someone
else in the body but in the right is the
immunohistochemistry
staining for sox10 that shows us that
the
this has the chemistry of melanocytes
it's derived from melanocytes
and if you look at the very top you'll
see a
a necklace of cells right at the
epidermal boundary those are the normal
melanocytes
and this tumor is derived then from
them so remember this sucks 10 because
we're going to come back to it
now if we further our analysis
and with pcr assay look for allele
specific mutations
we find that b raf v 600 e mutation
and that seems to be good news and
here's why
there is a specific anti-vraf
b600e mutation drug
and furthermore if you see
in the survival curve the top line here
is showing you the benefit to gain
and progression-free survival if you're
um b-ref e-600e positive and receive
that drug
versus a person who gets only the
standard chemotherapy
so one thing to notice about this scale
notice the x-axis is in months
so our patient thinking it's just a
little pe
and no big deal is actually facing this
timing
of nine mo nine months
but for the moment the good news is
there's a mutation
there's a drug mutated a drug directed
at that mutation
and and so this is where we are we we
look at it as um we found this
a sequence which is targetable um we
have a drug to affect that
um we must be in uh
in high clover here but i'll just point
out something
if you go back here um
notice that although the patients um
with the anti-viral treatment uh
do much better for a good uh
five or six months notice where both
curves end up
so recurrence is a factor and this
becomes more apparent
when we do this we're going to take our
patient and go deeper
we're going to do next gen sequencing
and lo and behold it's not one mutation
it's all together 10 mutations
and this is a hyper-mutated state
commonly associated with sun uh
with melanomas of solar damage
and so we come to this point that our
drug
affects one of these mutations but not
the others
and it leads to this
you begin to get into this situation
that hercules was in
2500 years ago fighting the hydra which
is
what does it mean if you lop off one
head
right you've got the other heads to deal
with
and so this is all too often the problem
that tumors evolve genetically
and there's more than one mutation
involved
so let's get at the logic of this
the good news is um there
there is a magic bullet it is precise
there is an fda approved diagnostic um
but the bad news is that tumors
hypermutate and they evolve
and and attacking it from the point of
view of
one mutation doesn't do it so
what do we to use multiple specific
treatments and then there's the fact
that any of one of these agents
happens to coincidentally spark
other pathways so what's our solution
are we going to go with
polypharmacy multiple mutation specific
drugs given in a cocktail our cocktail
would have what ten
or is it possible that we take a
different strategy
i'll go back to this
right here
what if instead of going for the heads
what if we go for the body
what if the body has attributes in
common
so is this a tenable strategy
is there any scientific basis to
thinking this way
and just bear with me for a minute i
think there's some
work in this area that suggests that yes
finding that phenotypic driver may be
the key
and it goes back to this seminal paper
which is published about the
genetic branched evolution this happens
to be in the circumstance of renal
carcinoma
and when you read this paper it
it reads very frighteningly
as if we're never going to succeed uh
one mutation at a time
because of this evolution but
the the paper ends and the last
statement in that paper says something
very interesting in tumor heterogeneity
there's genetic divergence
with consequent phenotypic convergence
which alters cell function at the
protein level
and the way i translate this
is for all those ongoing genetic changes
there comes a dominant driving force
which is a common denominator of the
function of those cells
it may not be one protein driving force
but there may be a couple and the key
seems to be to get at the cell function
that's involved
so let's ask the question is there such
a phenomenon
occurring in our patient could we attack
the body
instead of the head so
we're going back to the patient now
here's what we know we know from the
next gen sequencing
that this person this patient's tumor
is hypermutated and you can say
uh the consequence of that is they
should be
hyper immunogenic and that
um in fact classically uh those few
people that survived this
a really malignant melanoma did mount
a self-healing response it's just that
with that many mutations
and the rapid growth of that tumor
the cd8 cells become exhausted
right so um
it and also the response to those
mutations
can be blunted by an immune blockade
protein
okay and which down regulates the t cell
activation
that's another complication
the tumor itself can cause a loss of
immuno
surveillance but let's say in this
patient we find that that immune
blockade protein is there
that this acquired immune resistance is
operative
then we do have a whole armamentarium
of relevant drugs that should promote
self-healing
so let's let's go back to our patient
now remember
he had a metastatic lymph node so this
was in the neck of this patient
there are 45 lymph nodes and this was
the one lymph node
that had the melanoma in it and what
you're looking at
is from low power
in the microscope a section
of this lymph node again stained with
hematoxylin and niacin
and the paler parts of this are where
the melanoma is
the dark parts are where the lymphocytes
are
and what we want to look at ask the
question
is there some phenotypic property found
in the pale cells that we could get at
in terms of treatment
some common denominator and particularly
we're wondering
uh has it put up an immune blockade we
could attack
so we go to multiplexing
immunohistochemistry
and um what we've done is we've painted
pdl1 brown we've painted
the wolves of the immune system cd8
green
and we've painted uh the
t-cell inactivation molecule pd1 red
and i call your attention to the upper
left i think it's the most
obvious there you see how some of those
tumor nodules are
are very pdl pdl1-positive they're
surrounded by red
uh pd1 inactivated cells
and notice that that the wolves of the
immune system the cd8
are mainly outside not inside the tumor
and so we this is what immune blockade
looks like
this is what you get when you have
intact tissue when you're studying it
you see the field of play you see the
relationship
between one element and the other
and actually this high pdl
with nearby but not invasive tills
is the very circumstance in which
anti-pd1 and anti-pdl-1
drugs are the most effective so
this patient very intelligently would be
treated with an
anti-pd1 or pdl1
and so uh here's the patient
treated with anti-pd1 happens to be
uh in the oncology ward at ucla
and it happens to be me
um and this is a picture taken in one of
the
21 times i went to la to get an
infusion of katruda over a year
um i had generally it wasn't that
difficult
um it was a little inconvenient flying
back and forth but and there were some
side effects like itchiness
and uh and blister formation and
and nausea and so on but really they
were minor compared to the really scary
part of this therapy
was the trip on the freeway between lax
and ucla
that was truly scary but the other part
of it
i was went pretty well and i had the
benefit that
this was in 2015 it was right at this
moment in time when the dosing had been
worked out
so that helped me it also happened to be
the moment in time
you may remember when jimmy carter the
american president
had presented with a metastatic melanoma
to the brain
and liver and he went on this same
anti-pd1
um and you know that james is
alive today so it was just the beginning
of
understanding that
immune blockade drugs could make a big
difference
and so for me so far so good
here's a picture of me with my immediate
family
a wife a daughter son
their spouses and my five grandkids
were about to fly off into the bush in
south africa
so uh yeah thanks to
being well treated now you can look at
at this patient this circumstance and me
and say from a scientific point of view
look it's an antidote it's one person
okay you can add jimmy carter to it but
that's still the few
but what's really important you don't
change medicine based on a couple people
that let's say got lucky um it's really
based on taking the next step
which is how do you universalize this
how do you get it
to everyone how do you get it to every
patient
in this circumstance so that's the
third part of this talk we're going to
talk about which is how
how therapy has gone from the few to the
many
and in the case the specific and i'm
going to discuss
two diseases here one of them is
malignant melanoma and the other one
is breast cancer in the case of the
malignant melanoma
the red letter day in which we went from
the few to the many
um was on the 10th of may 2018
when a population-based study with more
than a thousand patients
with stage three melanoma in 13
countries
who were treated post-resection with
anti-pd1
showed a 30 percent improvement in
relapse-free
survival so
what comes out is that um this
now is the new global standard and the
reason you can say that
is because you're not doing this at one
or two famous universities
uh to be promulgated
uh out from there over many years you
start
by doing it on a global scale so
i think uh this is a very impor
important uh hallmark in
our immunotherapy is its globalization
my second example of the
universalization
is triple negative breast cancer
immunotherapy
so if you have any familiarity with this
disease
it's an uncommon form of breast cancer
but it was considered medically
as uniformly fatal with the median
survival of just
18 months and the red letter day for
this
breakthrough immunotherapy for this
triple negative came in november
2018 again published in the new england
journal of medicine
and it was the demonstration that the
immune blockade drug anti-pdl-1
decentric plus taxane
was a game changer so this was a study
with 945 patients
randomized in uh and
run in 200 randomized and blinded and
run
in 246 locations in 41 countries
and if you were a patient
receiving anti-pdl-1
whose t-till cells
were pdl-1-positive then your
progressive-free survival
was 25 months versus
15 months for the non-pdl one positive
and your hazard ratio was 0.62
versus 0.80 so if you know hazard ratios
1.0 would be no gain in
survival and as you go closer to zero
there's a gain in survival so
what this trial showed is that
the phenomenon of immune blockade
and the anti-blockade therapy
based on the circumstance of
the phenotypic properties and the immune
status of this patient
had a higher probability probability
of success
there's a statement the very last
statement in this paper
is it is important for patients pdl1
expression status
on tumor infiltrating immune cells to be
taken into consideration
to inform treatment for patients with
metastatic triple negative breast cancer
and so remember the title of this talk
is the importance
of intact tissue chemistry
and so that ability to see where the
players are
it's not just that you had some tissue
that you ground up and found pdl-1
no it's finding the pdl-1 on the till
and that is the critical determinant
here
of the likelihood of response
there's another aspect of this study
that i think is really important
and that is it was done in 41 countries
and it was done in i say below
945 patients in 18 months
okay but what was absolutely unique is
all these patients were essentially
studied in a few months
they were they were given the same drugs
the latest greatest and then they all
had the same diagnostic it was automated
immunistic chemistry
with the same assay on an automated
instrument
the it's the automated diagnostic
that allows you to produce the same
results
all over the globe and this turns out to
be very important in the case of triple
negative breasts
because it's uncommon and if you were in
a single university
to try to run this study and get 945
patients you would probably be seven or
eight years
accumulating the patients and those
patients would not have been studied
at the same moment in time but because
all these patients were studied
within weeks of each other because
they all had the same test with the same
interpretation by the same methodology
with the same drugs then you can
become very assured about your statement
about what's going on
and then something else has happened and
that is whereas the historic precedent
was starting at a university and
eventually making it
to other countries this started other
countries
and became the global standard on day
one
okay so i think this is what our future
looks like
just one other comment about this
there's one other oddity here and that
is this
antibody sp142 particularly highlights
pdl1 on ttil
and it's a characteristic of that
antibody
and i think it is an interesting quirk
of immunology
to explain is is this an iso
isomeric form of pdl1 i mean what
explains this
oddity but i can tell you exactly the
same phenomenon
has been found in urinary bladder cancer
as well
so we come to the fourth part which is
the future directions
and the fact is we don't know nearly
enough
there are many more response elements
than what i've been talking about
there's a lot more to this than pdl1 and
pd1
there's a lot more of a need
to predict who will response and to
monitor response
there's a study which i think i i
call your attention to out of tony
ribasta's lab and
published in nature in november 2014 and
i think
it heralds what the future looks like
and that is
he studied patients in which they did
sequential biopsies
pre-treatment and during treatment they
followed the response they followed the
spatial aspect
they determined whether there was till
invasion
they followed activation they followed
proliferation
of the effector cells and whether those
cells were
enzymatically equipped to kill and so on
and i think
that approach which went from single
analytes to multiplexing
and that giving us the possibility of
monitoring
treatment is defines what our future
looks like
so i recommend that one paper to you
now um i i think a key
thing for us to understand is that we
need to leave the world of
one analyte at a time i mean we we're
hooked on
uh just show me the pdl1 but as i'm
about to show you
they're more a response elements there
are more cells involved
and more more types of cancer to be
studied so really important in this
future endeavor to enter the world of
multiplexing
it's going to look more like this so
i'll show you two examples
one of them is a multiplex here's a five
plex chromogenic
and this is the world we need to enter
the these are
in these five colors from the green pd1
to the yellow macrophages to the um
to the turquoise cd8 cells the
uh the purple uh what are they cd3
and you can make out here and there some
silver stain cells
those the the fox p3 positive probably
the t-rex
but where what's really important in our
future studies is
we've come to this point of a much
higher
uh capability uh with multiplexing
i mean what's remarkable here is the
colors don't mix
uh they're sharp and they are they
reveal the lay of the land and remember
in what we want to do
the spatial orientation being preserved
is very important
one other example now i'll go to
fluorochromes
and i'll return to metastatic melanoma
and this is again a five-plex but
um on the the the red ball
you see on the left side of the slide
stains with uh sox10 you remember that
that's telling us that this is a
melanoma
and then what you notice is this kind of
bright rim around the outside
those are the immune cells the till
that as you see has not entered the
tumor effectively
and really there's a lot going on at
that edge and let's go
to the higher magnification and now
we're seeing this not only from the
point of view of pd1 which is
here in what is it in its green
and the cd8 is in turquoise
but notice now new elements
the lag three and the tim three and it
turns out
that acquired immune resistance uh
t-cell exhaustion um
t-cell in a in a inhibition
is driven by more than pd
one it's driven also by these other
factors
like lag three and tim three so
look at where we are in 2020
okay so begin looking all the way over
to the right where it says t
cell exhaustion you see a cd8 cell
and look at that it's up regulated lag
three and tim
3 and pd1 it's exhausted it's headed
leave me alone
i've done enough you're on your own okay
now preceding that go all the way over
to the left
you see that the word t-a-c-e
that's trans-arterial chemoembolism
this is and then hcc this is a hepatic
carcinoma that's been treated with taste
and there's a storm of tumor antigens
and now there are two elements of the
response to the storm
one of them is all of the antigen
presenting cells like the dendritic cell
you see in just about the middle there
in the light blue
stimulates uh t-cell response
stimulates in essence an inflammatory
response
uh in association with macrophages and
t helper cells and you have a cd8 respon
inflammatory response even at a distance
to this
that over time becomes exhausted from
the sheer unrelenting stimulus
and then the new part we've all come to
understand
is the part in the middle below okay in
which
you see the tumor cell hcc expressing
pdl1 and blocking the cd8 cell
and now you see the interplay with
t-regs and
accessory presenting cells and
all the other factors at play so clearly
to understand what's going on here
from the point of view of one of these
markers
is not sufficient
so here's my conclusion and that is
i i believe that immuno oncology and
the treatment immunotherapy is highly
informed
by intact tissue chemistry i do
think it is revealed a fair amount from
the point of view of
single analytes but it is nearly
not enough we need to universalize to
more types of cancer
many more markers where you know where
do you see
in this in standard analysis the lag
three and the tim three
and the t-reg status and so on
that that should become part of our
everyday vocabulary
and multiplexing should be
the absolutely what we're used to seeing
every single day and then we need to
understand that
a patient with malignant melanoma a
patient with
triple negative breast cancer is not
occurring in
one country with uh sophisticated
medical
capability it's occurring all over the
world and our goal should be to reach
everyone
and i think one of the things we're
learning in these studies
is that's possible and that should be
our
imperative that medicine is the same all
over the world
and we need to focus on predicting and
monitoring
as a more informed way to proceed
so that's my presentation thank you for
your attention
and i'm happy to answer questions